i also wanted to add that when it comes
to making money because a lot of guys
are like well where do i start how do i
make that kind of bank so i can earn
the top ten percent five percent one
percent like how can i be a one percent
guy sort of thing like
well the main categories are going to be
high ticket sales
so you're selling yachts private jets
you know
5 million plus mansions expensive [ __ ]
basically
because commission is always a
percentage of the value of the
transaction so high ticket sales would
be the first i would say any c-suite job
ceo cfo cto c-o-o
whatever like anything that's that's
board room type of executive where
you're
you know sitting at the table with all
the big boys if you can get yourself
into that sort of position that's always
a well-paying job
entrepreneurship is by far my favorite
probably
probably because it's it's it can be the
quickest path and with the most personal
freedom and flexibility because it gives
you the power to tell people to go [ __ ]
themselves
and it's okay because we're like 28
minutes into the video so you can swear
now maybe like once or twice but yeah
you can actually like put yourself in a
position where you can tell somebody to
go [ __ ] themselves and there's nothing
more powerful that
than that being able to have fu type of
positioning exactly so
that's a beautiful thing you can't get
like one of the funny things that
happened is if i go on twitter and i say
here's six things that you got to do
ladies to keep a guy
and then i'll get like swarmed by the um
you know outrage mob and they'd be like
oh you're richard cooper that works at
total debt freedom blah blah blah oh
yeah you know we're gonna file a
complaint it's like
have fun [ __ ] i own the company what
are you gonna do fire me you don't like
it
get lost pound sand right that's that's
just the approach that that
you can have when you get to that
position so and that's attractive right
like women just don't
like the uh strength and flexibility and
the options that money brings
they also like the fact that you put up
with less crap because they want to
because they basically want to stand
behind
i mean winners i mean they don't want to
stand behind losers that's just the way
that women are you can't really
ever change that facts which is facts
yeah absolutely and it's hard man
entrepreneurship isn't for everybody
everyone calls on themselves an
entrepreneur but how many of them might
be like literally living off of their
entrepreneurship a lot of people like
kind of
call themselves an entrepreneur but they
drive uber on the side you know what i'm
saying so yep
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
i feel like that word has been thrown on
losers you think now
don't don't don't brag if you're not
there don't don't ever walk around
bragging
you know as if you're all the [ __ ] let
let what it is that you do brag for you
let all of that speak for you you know
that's those guys get called out and
then they just end up getting destroyed
it's unfortunate that they can get on
oh and the last thing with making bucks
deluxe too so so we covered uh high
ticket sales c-suite jobs
entrepreneurship
i'd say the next main category would be
uh professional type of designations
doctor surgeon lawyer uh you know
dentistry like
the higher end stuff like i'm not
talking like you know i'm a nurse sort
of thing but more like
surgeon you know look it
if you're highly skilled in a certain
area you're always going to get paid
well you know you're definitely going to
get
be getting paid over 300 000 when you're
a seasoned
medical professional legal professional
it just works out that way
some of it's very hard work though i
mean to become a lawyer to make that
kind of money
you're gonna have to do five to ten
years of
like grudging work i mean you ask um
esquire um andrew esquire you know he'll
tell you straight up like it's a grind
right
yeah it's just like the more i always
say the more niche you are
the better because the more niche you
are the less people that you're
competing with and the higher prices you
can demand for your service
like a brain surgeon can demand half a
million dollars or more a year
because there's only a few those versus
a general practitioning doctor
you know they're going to make
significantly less because they're more
general so yeah i would say
something that people don't talk about a
lot is software so you can literally
learn how to code from your bedroom
right
and then you can like develop they
basically start you with facebook at
like a
200 thousand dollars a year yeah dude
you know that being in your bedroom
learn how to code c plus plus
java python and legit you leave that
spot you get you you do some projects
you show it to an employer and the thing
with software is that like you don't
have to have a degree you can literally
get in there
have some projects on the table yeah you
like your work we'll hire you
and it you might start 100k 200k so it's
like you can get in the door
with a little barrier and less amount of
time ai
ai and software is big i had a coaching
client a few months ago
um he was originally from india and he
was living
in silicon valley i think he was working
for facebook and by year five he was
making like 780 000
a year damn um so you can make serious
money in
that space too um it's not correlated
you know directly with
strong masculine virtues unfortunately a
lot of a lot of guys in that space you
know
tend to get painted with the same brush
but you can stand out from the crowd by
doing some work on yourself
you